hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the groundwork
for the metaphysics of morals when he's
introduced the first formulation of the
categorical imperative which is only on
that Maxim that which you can at the
same time will that it should be a
universe become a universal law of
nature it can't actually gives you some
examples and he gives you four in that
section in in Section two of the
groundwork but he also gave you another
one earlier with the question about the
shopkeeper should he give a good price
or not a fair price to to all of his
clients so we're gonna look at the cons
examples and then in another video we'll
look at some other examples that could
have considered but didn't consider that
might help you dry this home a little
bit more so he says well now enumerate a
few duties following their customary
division into duties towards self and
duties towards others and this is a is
an important idea sometimes people think
that we don't actually have duties
towards herself we only have duties
towards other other people that you know
when it comes to herself anything goes
we can do anything we like because so
long as I don't affect other people
it doesn't matter
I'm a moral person yeah and there are
certain moral theories which see it that
way kanji and a ontology doesn't see it
that way
instead it views it as there being
certain duties which you actually have
to yourself which you have to observe
I'm actually gonna skip the first one
and come back to that in a moment
because I want to start talking about by
I want to start talking about duties
towards others because I think we have a
better conception of those on a gut
level than we do duties to our self so
he says another person finds himself
driven to borrowing money because of
need he well knows he will not be able
to pay it back and he sees too he will
get no loan unless he makes a firm
promise to pay it back within a fixed
time so a question here got a person who
needs something or want something the
question is is it okay for them to make
a lying promise to pay back alone so he
says he is inclined to make such a
promise but he has still enough
conscience to ask is it not unlawful and
contrary to duty to get out of
difficulties in this way so we can
broaden this what is the maxim here the
maxim is something along the lines of
when I find myself in difficulties I
will make a lying promise to that to get
myself the resources I need to get
myself out of the difficulties so
contactually puts it like this whenever
I believe myself short of money I will
borrow money and promise to pay it back
although I know this shall never be done
so he says this principle of self-love
or personal advantage is perhaps quite
compatible with my own entire future
welfare so you know if I think about
this only from the perspective of
prudence you know whether this would
turn out well for me by doing this sort
of thing then it doesn't sound like a
bad proposition because I'll get myself
out of the trouble so life goes on
nicely for me but I can ask
so is this right the categorical
imperative is saying again remember act
only on that max of only the things that
you can actually make fit this this set
of rules this this set of criteria here
only those things are actually right so
he says how would things stand if my
maxim became a universal law what would
it be like if I imagined a world in
which everybody whenever they found
themselves in difficulties would make
promises with no intention of ever
keeping them so he says I see straight
away this maxim can never rank as a
universal law of nature and be
self-consistent now that's a really
important term right there can never be
self-consistent would be inconsistent
but it must necessarily contradict
itself for the universality of a law
that everyone believing himself to be a
need can make any promises with the
intention not to keep it here's where
the key point is would make promising
and the very purpose of promising itself
impossible no one would believe that he
was being promised anything but would
laugh at utterances of this one is empty
shams so what count is saying is if you
try to imagine this we're trying to try
to you know think out what this would be
like try to wrap your head around the
world in which everybody has the maxim
that whenever I'm in in some sort of
difficulties I will make a lying promise
then the very notion of promising begins
to unravel or collapse kind of portrays
it as if it like happens immediately you
know you think this out and you just see
it like that I'm not quite so sure that
that it suggests itself so so readily
but in any case that's that's what he
thinks is going on so that tells you
about something that is a strict duty to
other people you actually have a strict
duty according to Kant not to make lying
promises or winstrol another way of
putting that
is when you make a promise to somebody
you have to fulfill that promise you
have to at the time that you're making
it intend to fulfill that promise
that's a duty now let's look at a strict
duty to the self so now we're dealing
with something that we don't normally
think that much about when we're doing
doing our ordinary ethics we don't often
think of our health ourselves as having
duties to our self and when we do talk
in that way in our ordinary and common
sense morality it's it's it's often so
that we can indulge ourselves when we
haven't indulged yourselves for a while
and that's very different than what Kant
would would actually go along so he says
imagine a case where a man feels sick of
life as a result of a series of
misfortunes that is mounted to the point
of despair but he is still so far in
possession of his reason as to ask
himself whether taking his own life may
not be contrary to his duty to himself
now I was doing it to other people so
he's not talking about somebody saying I
can't kill myself because I have to take
care of my my spouse and my children or
because it'll make people upset or
anything with that he's saying look take
all that aside do you have a duty to
keep your life going on even if you are
no longer happy in your in your life
even if you're miserable so he says he
now applies the test can the maxim of my
action really become a universal law of
nature so what is the maxim that Kant
says that the maxim is from self-love I
make it my principle to shorten my life
if its continuance threatens more evil
than it promises pleasure let's read
that one more time because that's kind
of a mouthful from self-love I make it
my principle so it's my maxim that I
will shorten my life if its continuance
threatens more evil than it promises
pleasure so if my life is going to be
disagreeable to me I will shorten my
life so this doesn't necessarily have to
be like you know driving off the bridge
or shooting oneself or taking the pills
this could be you know if my life
my life doesn't look very good to me it
looks like it's not gonna be very nice
then I won't do anything to take care of
myself it could it could fit into that
as well so what would happen that if we
imagine a world like that he says it is
seen at once that a system of nature by
whose law the very same feeling that is
self-love right the very same feeling
whose function is to stimulate the
furtherance of life should actually
destroy life would contradict itself and
consequently could not subsist as a
system of nature so conscious saying
there is a contradiction there in this
case in that the very the very impulse
that you have of self-love to to take
care of yourself to further life to to
you know stride after things that you'll
actually enjoy would be turned against
itself and sort of nullify itself so he
sees a a logical contradiction there and
he says because there's a logical
contradiction of that you can't make it
a universal law of nature so therefore
you can't act on that maxim if you want
to be moral it would be immoral to kill
yourself so those are strict duties now
let's look at less strict duties what we
call meritorious duties but again let's
start with other people mariette
meritorious duties to others so he says
a person is flourishing so he's doing
well but he sees others we have to
struggle with great hardships and whom
he could easily help and he thinks what
does it matter to me let everyone be as
happy as heaven wills or as he can make
himself
I won't deprive him of anything so this
is a person who says I'm doing well I
see other people who are who are in dire
need or are suffering and I'm not going
to help them I'm not going to hurt them
but I'm also not going to help them I'm
just going to leave them there so if
they're starving let them starve if
they're
if they're cold I'm going to let them be
called if they are grieving I will let
them breathe you could think of actually
you know you can run down the whole
Beatitudes right for this thing you know
he says I won't nvm I only have no wish
to contribute anything to as well-being
or to his support in distress now
concepts you can actually make that
become a universal law of nature that is
conceivable there is nothing inherently
contradictory in a state of affairs in
which everybody like he says everybody
just you know keeps their hands off of
everybody else it doesn't help anybody
out and just you know treats them as
well as they can but without you know
actually improving their their condition
so he says such an attitude if it became
a universal law mankind could get on
perfectly well so imagine something like
a marketplace where human beings just
treat each other according to the rules
of the game nobody nobody tries to
improve anybody else's case so he says
actually this would be better in some
respects then if everybody prates about
sympathy and goodwill and even takes
pains on occasion to practice them but
on the other hand cheats where he can
traffics and human rights or violates
them in other ways so he's saying this
is better than a case of hypocrisy as a
matter of fact this is one of those
things where you might actually have an
example here Kahn would say hypocrisy
would be violating a strict duty to
others beneficence doing well to other
people that's a meritorious day he says
you can imagine a world in which
everybody says ask for everybody else
I'm not going to take care of that
they're on their own I I'm not gonna
hurt them in any way
I'm not going to take anything away from
them but I'm not going to do anything to
help them out you can imagine that world
can you will it it doesn't make sense
Kahn says to will a world like that
because you would be willing a world in
which you yourself might actually need
somebody's help sometime you know if you
think about this in very practical terms
you come into this world needing help
and you actually need help for a great
many years and many of us will actually
leave this world needing other people's
health as well and sometimes for a great
many years as well so this is not
something purely imaginary this is
something that's part of the human
condition
so Khan says you can't will it which
means that it becomes a meritorious duty
to help others that means that if you
don't help others you're not actually
going contrary to a strict duty you're
not being immoral but you're not being
moral you're being moral if you do in
fact help other people the other case
that he talks about would be a
meritorious duty to yourself this is a
very interesting one because this
actually ties into the whole idea of
education and education as something
constant saying this is something I'm
saying this ties in with the idea of
education as being something that you
take ownership of as we say these days
so he says a person finds it himself a
talent who's cultivation would make him
a useful man for all sorts of purposes
but he sees himself in comfortable
circumstances and he prefers to give
himself up to pleasure rather than to
bother about increasing and improving
his fortunate natural aptitudes so this
person could be developing themselves
into the kind of being who would
actually make other people's lives in
some way better would help them out but
he says hey I've already got it you know
pretty pretty nice I don't need to do
that sort of thing I don't need to
develop myself oh this could be going to
trade school this
be working on their their moral
dispositions this could be going to
college or university learning and
discipline and study says I'm just going
to take it easy so he asks himself
though does my maxim of neglecting my
natural gifts
besides agreeing in itself with my
tendency to indulgence agree also with
what is called duty
so again Khan says let's think about
this can you think of a world can you
imagine can you can you wrap your head
around a world in which everybody would
behave in such a way nobody would
develop them themselves everyone would
say well I've got perhaps talents but
I'm not gonna work on them because
things are nice enough for me already
yeah he says yeah you could imagine this
a system of nature could always subsist
under such a universal law although
every man should let his talents rust
and should be bent on devoting his life
solely to idleness indulgence
appropriation and an award to enjoyment
could you have a society if you won't
put this in our terms could you have a
society purely of consumption and
enjoyment and not of self development
self cultivation education this is a
live possibility in art you know a lot
of people would that be the right thing
to do
Khan says you can imagine a world in
which this occurs there would be an
inconsistency and willing it and if the
inconsistency in willing it is very very
different than the inconsistency in
saying you know with the the meritorious
duties to others I I might you know find
myself in a world where I need help or
something like that in this one it has
to do with the very nature of a rational
human being and he says he cannot
possibly will that this should be a
universal law of nature or should be
implanted in us as such a law by natural
instinct for as a rational being he
necessarily wills that all his powers be
since they serve him and are given him
for all sorts of possible ends that's a
really interesting thing to say Todd
says as a rational being now remember
we're not always fully rational right as
a rational being he necessarily wills
that all his powers be developed so
within every person even the person
who's just a pure consumer doesn't do
anything laze around watches TV all day
eats potato chips drinks beer and you
know think whatever else you want and
they don't develop anything insofar as
they're rational being they're still
good they're going against the
rationality they will that they develop
their talents their abilities their
possibilities that they they develop
that potentiality into actuality Cohn
thinks that we all have a meritorious
duty to ourself to improve ourselves and
that comes from our rationality that
doesn't come from the fact that it's
going to gonna make us rich or any
anything you know that we enjoy what
we're studying Kant thinks that this is
part of our duties to ourself the other
the other case that Kant does talk about
with the shopkeeper who gives fair
prices that would fit into strict duties
to others and you could apply the
categorical imperative to that as well
you could say can you turn cheating into
giving a unfair price into something
like a universal law of nature and if
you imagined a world in which everybody
would give an unfair price to everybody
else I think God would say there's going
to be an inherent logical contradiction
to that world the very notion of
fairness and price would just sort of
vanish and disappear you'd have no way
of comparing it and so it would be
come in consistent so we have you know
four main and a few other examples that
can't give of how you actually apply
this categorical imperative I hope that
this has helped you in understanding
that and we'll look at some other
examples in another video